[تصفيق]
اسكت احسن الجدل اخيرا في حقيقه مقتل قائد
فاغنر واوكرانيا تتلقى ضربه موجعه وبغرابه
شديده وعشرون دوله جديده تقدم الضمانات
يتحدثون والشريان الروسي يعجز الغرب عن
قطعه او فرض عقوبات عليه فما هو واشنطن
تخسر طائره عسكريه في استراليا وضحاياها
من المارينز والاتحاد الاوروبي يتحضر
لاطلاق عمليه عسكريه في افريقيا فماذا عن
النيجر والعاصمه النيجيريه وباريس في حاله
ترقب واستعداد والسعوديه تلوي ذراع امريكا
ردوخ غربي شيئا فشيئا يجد الغرب نفسه في
دوامه لا يستطيع الخروج منها واليوم وبعد
انغصت اقدام الغربيين في الوحل الروسي ها
هي المانيا تتراجع لاصرح المستشار الا
لماني
بانه سيتم دراسه قرارات برلين بشان تسليم
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا في المستقبل بعنايه
ولن تكون هناك اي قرارات متهوره هل كانت
قراراتكم السابقه متهوره يا هؤلاء نعم
يبدو ذلك فبعث الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا
ها هو الناتو يغير استراتيجيتها والعسكريه
ليؤكد ميخائيل بودياك مستشار رئيس مكتب
بيزيلنسكي ان وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
شارك في اجتماع سريا مع جنرالات على
الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه وحضره القائد
الاعلى لقوات حلف الناتو في اوروبا
الجنرال الامريكي كريستوفر كافولي
والادمره للبريطاني توني رداكان حيث طرح
تعديل النهجه الحالي ووضع خطط للمعارك
خلال فصل الشتاء المقبل واستراتيجيه
لمواجهه واستراتيجيه للمواجهه على المدى
البعيد وحسب تقرير الجارديان فان القوات
الاوكرانيه غيرت بعض الاجتماع نهجها على
الارض لتركز هجومها على محور زابوريجيا
برايكم هل سيجدي تغيير التكتيكات نفعا
سربكم نحن حيث لا نعتقد ذلك لان موسكو
تعتبر الحرب الاوكرانيه مساله حياه او موت
فقد قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ان روسيا تعتبر الحرب في اوكرانيا مساله
وجوديه واضاف ان المواجهه هي الخيار
الوحيد لدى موسكو وها نحن ناتي بالمصدر
كالعاده
قال نائب الرئيس مجلس الامن
الروسيا تعتبر الحرب في اوكرانيا مساله
نجوديه واضاف ان المواجهه هي الخيار
الوحيد لدى موسكو ومع ذلك كله فهناك سبب
غربي يمنعه من التشجيع على هزيمه روسيا
فقد اكدت وكاله بلومبرك ان الدول الغربيه
وخاصه الولايات المتحده تعتمد على
اليورانيوم الروسي ولا يمكنها الاستغناء
عنه واشارت الى ان الحكومه الغربيه لا
تفرض عقوبات على روساتوم لانها تهدد
بالحاق ضرر اكبر الاقتصادها مقارنه
باقتصاد روسيا نعم الغرب سيستمر بضخ
الاموال ليستمروا باستيراد اليورانيوم
الروسي ويشكل ذلك داعما رئيسيا لاقتصاد
موسكو فما فائده العقوبات مهلا مهلا فحتى
اليورانيوم الذي كانت واشنطن وباريس من
النيجر قد فلاشه بعض الانقلاب الحالي في
نيامي بدعم من فغنر الروسي فيا له من حصار
مطبق على الطاقه الغربيه لكن وعلى عكس
التيار الغربي قال الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديميرنسكي ان 20 دوله من الدول
الديمقراطيه الغنيه قررت الانضمام الى
اتفاق يقدم الضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا
مضيفا ان هناك اليوم ما يقرب من 30 دوله
في المجموع بما في ذلك مجموعه السابه وهنا
نعود الى الميدان الاوكراني حيث اعلن
القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه دوناتسك دينس
بوشيلان ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت اراضي
الجمهوريه اكثر من 60 مره خلال 24 ساعه
لترد موسكو بان قوته الجويه نفذت ضربه
الناجحه لاحد المطارات في مقاطعه تياب
مؤكده ان الضربه حققت هدفها واصابت كل
المواقع المستهدفه وكالمعتاد لابد من هجوم
اوكراني جويا حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسي عن
تدمير طائرتين بدون طيار اوكرانيتين فوق
اراضي مقاطعه
الروسيتين خلال ساعات قليله فيما قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان روسيا شنت هجوما خلال
الليل على واجزاء اخرى من اوكرانيا وان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي دمرت اربعه صواريخ
روسيه من طراز كروز خلال الغاره وبدورها
قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه انها صدت
عشرات الهجمات في خمسه محاور رئيسيه شرقيه
وجنوبي البلاد في وقت اكد فيه مستشار
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودياك تفوق
قوه بلاده في شبهات الجنوب وان الدفاعات
الروسيه بدات في الانهيار نحن لن نعلق
ولكن سناتيكم بالمصدر وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه قالت انها صدت عشرات الهجمات
في خمسه محاور رئيسيه على مستوى الجبهتين
وبلغه اليقين اكد مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه
تفوق قوات بلاده في الجنوب الاوكراني واما
فيما يخص الاشتباه في مقتل قائد فاغنار
وهي اهم حادثه خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه فقد اعلنت لجنه التحقيق الروسيه
رسميا بانه بناء على نتائج الفحوصات تم
تحديده جميع الاشخاص العشره الذين قتلوا
في كارثه جويه وقعت بمقاطعه شمال موسكو
قبل ايام وتابعت وفقا لنتائج هذه الفحوصات
تم التعرف على هويات جميع القتل العشره
وتتوافق اسمائهم تلك الوارده في قائمه
ركاب الطائره في الرحله المنكوبه فهل
اقتنع المشككون الان بنهايه بريجوجان
وبالعوده الى اوكرانيا اعلنت كيا
افتلاقيها ضربه موجعه من دون معرفه السبب
وذلك باعلانها مقتل ثلاثه من طيارها
العسكريين في حادث تصدم جوي فوق منطقه
غربي العاصمه ليعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
ان التحقيق جاري في قضيه مقتل الطيار
الثلاثه وهنا دعونا نطرح سؤالا بريئا
تصادمت الطائره قبل ان تصل طائره الابسط
عشر لاوكرانيا فكيف لو وصلت هل يستطيع
الاوكران قيادتها دون حوادث الاحداث
والتطورات
ذو المانيطار ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعد النظر في شروطها للتعاون
النووي مع السعوديه بسبب توسط نشاط الصيني
وايران وايضا لتح تقدم في التطبيع بين
المملكه واسرائيل يبدو ان امريكا تراجعت
عن مماطرتها في التعاون النووي مع الرياض
بعد ان قرر السعوديون ترك واشنطن
والاستعاده عنها بالتنين الصيني فاي شريك
نووي ستختاره المملكه بعد اليوم لقي ثلاثه
من عناصر مشاه البحريه الامريكيه المارينز
حتفهم بتحطم طائره مروحيه على جزيره نائيه
في شمال استراليا خلال تدريبات مشتركه
وقال مسؤول في مشاه البحريه الامريكيه في
بيان كان هناك 23 فردا على متن الطائره
وتاكد وفاه ثلاثه بينما تم نقل الخمسه
اخرين الى مستشفى رويال داروين في حاله
خطره كشفت وسائل اعلام اوروبيه عن نيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي بدء مهمه عسكريه مدنيه
جديده في غرب افريقيا في الخريف المقبل
مشيره الى ان الهدف منها تدريب محدد لنشر
عمليه مكافحه الارهاب هل هناك علاقه
للنيجر بالامر هذا وتشهد نيام حاله من
الترقب مع قرب انتهاء المهله التي حددها
المجلس العسكري لمغادره السفير الفرنسي
للنيجر وهدد المجلس العسكري باللجوء الى
القوه لاجبار السفير الفرنسي على المغادره
في حال لم تذعن باريس لمطلبه فيما كثف
انتشار قواته في شوارع العاصمه مع اعلان
وضع الجيش في حاله استنفار قصوى
[موسيقى]